nowadays everyone knows about the matrix
but when it first debuted in 1999 film
goers weren't quite sure what they were
in for the movies blend of such a large
existential framework with slick kungfu
action scenes elevated the Wachowski and
at everyone second-guessing whether they
take the blue pill or the red bill but
with two relatively new filmmakers at
the helm it's a bit of a surprise such
an ambitious concept ever made into
celluloid let alone spun such a cultural
phenomenon so let's take a look back at
how the matrix came to be such a central
part of the sci-fi film world in the
first place
odd origins it's safe to say that the
matrix would have never come to be if
not for one really crappy film 1995's
assassins was a lazy action vehicle for
Sylvester Stallone and Antonio Banderas
directed by Richard Donner in full
paycheck caching mode but assassins
wasn't just a bad movie
it was also the Wachowskis second
completed script which was ultimately
sold to Warner Brothers in the end the
script itself is what earned the parrot
deal with Warner Brothers the Wachowskis
developed a relationship with assassins
producer Joel Silver to whom they showed
their script for the matrix early on and
he was immediately blown away Sylva
remembered the minute I started reading
the script for the matrix I wanted to
see it but then the Wachowski said and
we want to direct it that was going to
be tough instead of taking a gamble on a
script that was obviously going to take
a BT budget to realize silver took a
more cautious approach
he greenlit bound a smaller piece about
lesbian lovers on the run from the mob
which there were Chow skis would write
in direct the film was then made on a
tight six million dollar budget and was
a hit with critics that was almost
enough to convince Warner Brothers to
let the newly minted directors proceed
with her passion project but there was
just one problem
while everyone seemed to agree that The
Matrix was a great script nobody
understood the Wachowskis vision in the
least there is no spoon so the siblings
had to improvise storyboarding producers
were so confused by the premise of the
matrix that the Wachowski turned to a
pair of illustrators named Steve's gross
and Jeff Darrow to present the premise
that a format others might understand
handled the storyboards illustrating
scenes in a dramatic noir like style
with a heightened sense of motion and
impact meanwhile Darrow handled concept
art now for the first time executives
were able to visualize how this crazy
script will translate to the screen it
was enough for Warner Brothers to
greenlight a 60 million dollar budget
for the matrix and the pre-production
artwork was so impressive that it was
collected at a hardcover volume the year
after the film's release casting calls
after executives hopped on board with
the Wachowskis vision they still wanted
to maintain some creative control over
the project the cast in particular was
to be decided by Warner Brothers even
though the Wachowskis had some opinions
of their own on the matter Keanu Reeves
was not the Wachowskis first choice for
the role of neo instead they had their
eyes on Johnny Depp
meanwhile the studio wanted someone like
Brad Pitt Val Kilmer or Will Smith all
of whom turned down the role this is
your last chance after this there is no
turning back
Neos casting was eventually whittled
down to a choice between death and
Reeves the latter of whom Warner
Brothers preferred eventually the studio
went out with the casting of Reeves and
at least one star who turned down has no
regrets Will Smith has said he's glad he
turned down the role as Reeves ended up
being brilliant fight preparation the
Wachowskis envisioned the fight scenes
in the matrix being heavy on fast paced
close quarters martial arts combat with
elements of wire work so they decided to
appeal directly to the world's foremost
authority and martial arts choreography
Yuen woo-ping director of such classics
as drunken master and the man who made
Jackie Chan a star Yoon wasn't
interested until II read the script
unlike Warner Brothers executives it
took Yun almost no time to understand
what they were doing and he agreed to
bring his crew of trainers to the
production where his work began months
before the cameras ever started rolling
all of the movie stars were expected to
perform their own stunts but most
weren't exactly known for being
on-screen fighters so they had to spend
months training with Yun's kung-fu crew
and wire workers and suffered a few
injuries along the way and while it was
a brutal preparation process the ends
definitely justify the means for these
matrix stars
satisfying the suits it's an
often-quoted piece of trivia that Warner
Brothers initially budgeted the film at
10 million only to have the Wachowski
use it to create a smash opening
sequence and convinced the studio to
fund the full 60 million they needed but
that's not exactly how it happened
according to special effects supervisor
John Gaeta the australia-based
production had been scheduled for a 90
days shoot and it became obvious at a
certain point that it was falling
significantly behind executives were
growing frustrated so they hatched a
plan to clean up the opening sequence of
his visual effects and add in some
temporary sound effects once that was
done they sent it to the studio to let
them know just how production was coming
along after that Warner Brothers
immediately backed off and gave them an
additional month to complete the film it
was just enough time to make all that
movie magic happen including the
invention of a new photography technique
to capture those slow-mo bullet shots
Gaeta was inspired by the Japanese film
Akita and music video director Michel
Gondry to improvise his camera
techniques to create those memorable
scenes he used over 100 steel cameras
and 2 motion cameras to create the
effect of a shot moving into extreme
slow motion while the camera appears to
pan around or track the events at a
normal speed each sequence that employed
the technique was first digitally
simulated then meticulously staged with
the camera array programmed to shoot in
a specific sequence with precise timing
this technique became known as bullet
time camerawork and is a registered
trademark of Warner Brothers so not only
did they get a full-on franchise out of
the deal but they also made movie
history with the matrix thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]